[Music]
and a good afternoon to you thank you so
much for joining us at four i'm kirsten
joyce this is an historic day at a
legion stadium with the first raiders
game
in their brand new stadium brian
that's right kirsten brian loftus here
at allegion stadium right outside the
stadium we have team coverage chris
matthews
here to talk about the stadium molly
sullivan and rocky theist
talking to fans and john treats breaking
out keys to the game and then ron
futrell
will be talking about how we got here
let's get started though chris
it's unbelievable it's happening it is
absolutely happening this really is a
historic day when you think about it
four and a half years ago
raiders owner mark davis said hey made a
promise if you build and help fund a
stadium
he will bring his iconic franchise to
las vegas well guess what that day
has officially arrived the 2 billion
facility is set to go it opens tonight
monday night football
the wait is over inside this building
natural grass
pops like it's almost artificial but
it's natural
the big al davis torch is the
centerpiece of this facility where
hundreds of thousands of selfies
will be taken when fans are allowed
inside it overlooks the world famous
las vegas strip and there will be a
special person lighting that torch for
the first time tonight hey just who is
it
yeah okay so without opening the kimono
too much we've got a very special guest
coming to light the al davis torch
that's all i can say right now the the
ceremony is going to be fantastic i
think that
it's the perfect person and it'll
certainly start off the legacy of
lighting this al davis torch
here in las vegas for home games in the
future
are the doors going to be open no okay
so the doors won't be open
because it's still a little bit too hot
in las vegas we're hitting 100 degrees
every day
as we reach fall there's a good
opportunity for us to open those doors
[Music]
[Applause]
all right we mentioned there's going to
be a very special person lighting that
torch for the very first time
hey i know who it is if it's been leaked
out shame on that person
for letting the cat out of the bag
because it's going to be a big big deal
you can see over my right shoulder
raider nation fans gather in here
despite no fans allowed inside they're
pretty excited about this many have
waited in line for a few days just to
get some merchandise
from the brand the brand new raiders
image store that just opened this past
week hey
pinch me a little bit because this day
has finally arrived the nfl in las vegas
and it's the raiders reporting from
outside the legion stadium
with all these raider fans chris
matthews 8 sports now
thank you chris we'll check back with
you shortly allegiant stadium is opening
up in true las vegas
fashion the air force thunderbirds
demonstration team
will do a flyover during the national
anthem this evening
then at halftime las vegas own killers
they'll be performing
they'll be playing from the roof of
caesar's palace looking forward to that
brian
absolutely kirsten although fans are not
allowed inside allegiant stadium yet
there will be 65 000 fans there next
year they are
all over outside the stadium here they
are
you can see them they're passionate
they're enthusiastic
and they are loud molly sullivan has
been talking to somebody
we go live now to molly
[Applause]
hey clearly brian i will tell our eight
news now viewers that you are a man of
the people you've been an absolute hit
with raider nation here in the trenches
at allegiant stadium and look
our 8 news now crew has documented this
now historic relationship
it is 60 years in the making and really
one could argue that it's 100 years in
the making spanning the entire history
of the league you may recall raiders
owner mark davis declaring
on april 28 2016 that he wanted the
silver state to become the silver
and black state well mission complete as
you can see the fans here
in attendance at allegiant stadium a new
chapter rolls on tonight with the same
poise commitment to excellence and
gritty nature that we all know so well
now
hear me out on this one ron futrell
knows better than anybody but hear me
out on this and why i am bringing up the
unlv basketball program
and that's because unlv basketball there
was a time when
that was the hottest ticket in town and
i'm talking hotter than say
frank sinatra who oh by the way was a
big fan of unlv running rebels back in
the day right
but now that genuine star power is back
there is a type of swagger with the
organization that just fits las vegas it
just feels right so
the fans that i spoke with today at
allegiant stadium yes they are
disappointed that they are not
inside watching their raiders in this
home debut but in the same breath guys
they also understand the decision that
the raiders organization is committed to
the health of not only their players
their coaches their staff the facility
workers
but all of our neighbors right in the
community so listen good things come
to those who wait and i'm really excited
for this new chapter with all of you and
brian loftus you are the man of the
people over there i see everybody
surrounding you we'll have more
throughout the night guys
thanks so much molly i appreciate that
didn't really hurt what you said but
i heard something in there and i think
it was positive hey we want to tell you
about ndot is that right that's what
we're doing next they're warning people
not to gawk at the stadium and cause
traffic problems and they set a reminder
to drivers
not to stop at all on the freeway or
local roads to get a glimpse of the game
just one stop car can cause a chain
reaction as you can tell from looking at
it
no portion of the game will be visible
from outside the stadium
and eight news now recently took a
stadium tour
and we'll have more on that in just a
second we will we're looking forward to
that thank you brian we'll catch up with
you in just a matter of moments
and of course as they said things will
be closed but it'll be open
one day it's still a little hot out
there ted yeah still
hot and we've got some cloud cover too
temperatures also nice and warm but we
also have winds kj that's what we're
looking at right now double digit wind
speeds outside breezy winds the outflow
from nearby storms believe it or not we
want to go to our radar notice to the
east
very active but we're watching some
cells just to the south now raider
stadium located about
right here on your graphic but this one
you'll notice we have some isolated
cells they're moving their way up are we
looking at heavy rain for them no
we're primarily seeing very gusty winds
that we're seeing outside right now and
will continue early on the evening most
of the storms have been east of us
though in mohave county
look at these cells though made their
way into east clark even with some
lightning strikes there too so we're
keeping our eye
on those cells as well so here's your
game day forecast for the raiders can
you believe it breezy winds expected
at kickoff and of course halftime
temperatures in the mid 90s by
halftime and we'll keep it breezy like
we said until early evening more on your
forecast and what to expect
for the rest of this week all straight
ahead back to you thanks ted
we got to stock up on our gear and the
brand new store inside allegiant stadium
is called the raider image
it's 18 000 square feet loaded with
raider swag it's opened up last week
from jerseys to hats ooh that's a
spiffy jacket there purses lapel pins
allegiant stadium is cashless so you do
need to use a credit or debit card
and they of course are enforcing masks
and social distancing guidelines brian
all right kyrsten eight news now
recently took a stadium tour
of allegiant stadium chris matthews took
that or the death star as john gruden
has taken a call in it
and the 200 level concourse is really
impressive
it has more than 100 works of art
created by local las vegas artists and
former raiders quarterback
todd marinovich line the walls paying
homage to
raiders history and giving some props to
their new home city of las vegas
fans will see paintings of elvis presley
as a raider
carrot top evil knievel and the one and
only marilyn monroe as a raiderette
and i just want to say i think elvis
would have been a good raider white out
those fast feet
raiders themed portraits will remind the
raider nation faithful
of their favorite silver and black
moments including super bowl memories
and victories
you can see more of this unique in
allegiant art museum in chris matthews
behind the scenes stadium tour
over on eight news now dot com
thank you brian will certainly be nice
if the raiders can pull off a win in the
home opener
they're playing a very tough new orleans
saints team tonight john treach is out
at allegiant stadium as well with the
preview hi john
welcome to las vegas home of the raiders
we can't believe that it was 100 years
ago where we didn't say
that was even possible 20 years ago that
wasn't possible
four years ago not possible either in
fact
many didn't even think this day would
come a week ago but here we are
it did we've been baptized with big time
monday night football
few places in the world can put on a
show in the throes of a pandemic
where else can you be captivated by
aerial thrillers
musical killers and sports moment
chillers
vegas baby this city has hosted the
stanley cup a tantalizing amount of
title fights and every award show
not named oscar but never has it
showcased the nfl in a 2 billion
man-made marvel that's a whole new level
of hype
in history the saints and the raiders
that's uh that's monday night forward
it's best when you build a stadium like
this
i mean this is the force of nature
nothing's going to stand in its way
the newest las vegas headliner has a
headset i like the old
monday night football anthem to
highlights with howard cosell
doing them that was my monday night i
look forward to
monday is a night of moments the desire
to play never goes away
i'ma eat dinner and hopefully my mom
already cooked something and i'm a
you know be able to sit there and enjoy
it with my family and watch the game you
know that's that was
that was what we did growing up for four
years it's been we can't wait
now it's we're here and we belong
yeah we're caught up in the sport of
spectacle of tonight well the saints
just want to
beat the tar out of the raiders so that
makes for an intriguing matchup about an
hour away
back to you all right john thanks so
much
so exciting monday night football we all
remember that excitement back even when
we were kids
as shown in john's story now ron futrell
is going to talk about how the nfl
and the raiders in las vegas they were
very far apart a decade ago we didn't
know that this would happen
and of course it has finally now
happened with this incredible
2 million dollar stadium here's ron with
more
brian you are exactly right what do you
think about it there was a time
when the nfl wanted nothing to do with
las vegas the convention authority
tried to place ads during super bowl
games they were denied
the league didn't like the connection
with gambling especially sports betting
oh my how times have changed
when you consider the history tonight's
nfl game in las vegas
is absolutely remarkable there was a
time less than 20 years ago
when no las vegas ads were allowed
during the super bowl
and by 2010 they allowed some ads but
with restrictions there can be no gaming
iconography
there can be no long shots of the strip
you cannot be a building that has
gaming in it you can use entertainers
you can use a
generic sort of shock it's a thankless
job but i do it for you
so why the big change well the oakland
raiders needed a new home and the nfl
likes
big new beautiful stadiums not broken
down baseball stadiums like
oakland's alameda coliseum so the nfl
needed vegas and something had to give
in this relationship
the nfl backed down and now in fact
they have relationships with casinos and
gambling
it's rather interesting now there are
still restrictions on broadcasters
they're not
allowed to openly talk about odds and
point spreads
during games and during broadcasts like
well jimmy the greek snyder did in the
70s on cbs during nfl broadcast
but watch watch for that one to change
sometime
down the road brian back out to you at a
legion stadium where
it sounds exciting out there huh
back here at allegiant stadium excuse me
two billion dollar facility i said two
million i lowballed it there
incredible 1.75
million square feet and the fans are
here 65 000
fans cannot head into the arena the
stadium
this season but they're still here in
numbers including a lot of saints fans